good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is scp-1234 see Jers
scp-1234 each locker at site 12 access
requires minimum clearance to with
authorization and supervision by
clearance three research and security
staff respectively supervising personnel
are not to view a CP 12 30 s contents
personnel accessing a CP 1230 are
required to submit written accounts of
dreams experienced within 48 hours of
access see addendum 1230 a scp-1234
injure behind the desk of site 12 s main
library access is available to clearance
to personnel deemed to be in
satisfactory psychological condition by
site psychiatric staff personnel
accessing scp-1234 dreams within 48
hours of access and submit to follow-up
psychological examination description as
CP 1230 is an unlabeled green hardcover
book with no apparent exceptional
qualities when scp-1234 n-- on the first
page viewed while all other pages will
be blank
resetting once the book is closed this
has no obvious effects at first but upon
falling asleep the reader will dream of
a fantasy world where they are the
protagonist of a troubled land dreamers
are completely aware and all senses work
just as well as when awake results vary
depending on the imagination of the
reader and are mostly attuned to
fantasies of adventure that the reader
would enjoy in the mind of the reader
those dreams have been documented to
last anywhere from 45 second
see experiment 12 33 to 200 years see
experiment 12 35 but in reality the
reader will usually never be asleep
longer than they would normally upon
awaking the reader is able to remember
every aspect of their dream in detail an
SCP 1213 two-streams there is always a
character called the bookkeeper scp-1234
dead man in a green cloak who claims to
be the personification of scp-1234 has
been reported to be very amicable and
helpful to warns dreamers and has stated
that it enjoys creating these fantasy
escapes and always tries to shake them
in such a way that the dreamer Garner's
the most entertainment out of it it has
expressed sorrow when the dream comes to
an end and asks the dreamer please visit
again soon
discovery in a small bookstore located
and the shopkeeper had no recollection
of owning the unlabeled book but
attempted to sell a story to local
newspapers about a magical dream book
the foundation was able to dispel the
story as a hoax and SCP 12:30 was
confiscated experiment 12 3001 doctor in
an attempt to test its effective range
opened scp-1234 did a flight to his
hometown where he spent the night at a
hotel upon his return doctor reported
that scp-1234 n-- the dream is
immediately implanted into your
subconscious after which SCP 1231 is
able to manipulate it remotely doctor
and expressed his appreciation for SCP
1231 s cooperation
experiment 12:32 a camera was set up
above us EP 12:30 and using a mechanical
arm the book was opened all pages were
revealed to be blank it seems as CP
12:30 is only effective when opened by
beings that are able to have dreams as
CP 1231 explained to a subsequent
dreamer that it is actually only able to
affect beings with an imagination and
that most creatures such as animals
would not be affected experiment 12:30
Oh 3:1 d-class was instructed to open
the book and after much reassurance that
his experiences would only be dreams
ordered to immediately find a way to
kill himself in the dream the subject
was asleep for merely 45 seconds before
he awoke with a start in a nervous sweat
he reported being at the summit of a
volcano called the ashen spire on a
quest for Claudius the blessed blade
when asked how the subject knew the
names he stated it's like I knew them
all along he apparently lept into the
volcano and felt an intense heat before
awakening d-class requested permission
to give it another go
request was denied experiment 12 3000
for one d-class was instructed to open
the book and attempt to non fatally
injure himself in his dream after six
hours d-class awoke and reported that he
was able to feel a numb sort of pain
where it was never so intense as to be
unbearable he also reported meeting an
elderly cloaked man who asked him why he
was harming himself but thanked him for
not immediately killing himself like
that other rude fellow the British rude
fellow anyway experiment 12:30 o 5
professor filed a request for access to
scp-1234 his level 4 clearance staff
members recalled that Professor almost
visibly shaking with excitement and
reported that Professor was
avid fan of tabletop and role-playing
games surveillance shows that Professor
opened the book read the phrase sat down
beside the desk and promptly fell asleep
staff members were alarmed when
Professor ball not awake after 15 hours
an alerted security the on-site medical
staff were able to confirm that
Professor is still alive and in good
health
after approximately 24 hours since
falling asleep professor began to move
reported to have slowly raised his head
and looked around the room
appearing deeply confused security
entered the room to ensure he was
alright to which he replied where am I
he was sent to medical where staff
explained where and who he was several
minutes later professor appear to have
regained his memory and excused himself
to the restroom when 15 minutes passed
professor book did not exited a nurse
entered to find he had hanged himself
with his belt a scribbled message on the
wall revealed his last words I can't go
back to this doctor who went to ask us
EP 1231 what had happened but upon
opening scp-1234 soaking wet with the
same message on every page I'm so sorry
I never intended for this to happen I
just wanted to make people happy
repeated over and over SCP 1238 for
three weeks and it's desk had to be
wiped dry bi-weekly in an attempt to
communicate doctor placed a sticky note
in sinus EP 1230 with the statement i'd
like to talk to you if that's all right
the next morning doctor held a report
about a dream he had concerning a CP
1231
this is report 12:30 14 upon fully
asleep last night I dreamt I was in a
dark void there was a street lamp and
underneath it was scp-1234 sing in a
puddle his cloak was visibly sucked as
he was sobbing profusely
I remember our conversation and went
something like this
well keeper is that you my god man where
are we
the bookkeeper replied between sobs I
couldn't think of anything to make for a
landscape I replied but people what
happened that day
why did professor kill himself we have
to know your side of the story
the bookkeeper still crying wiping his
eyes responded he had such an active
imagination I was able to create a vast
and beautiful universe for him and was
obvious that he had wanted a life like
that for so long a conquered foul beasts
and rescue princesses he'd built
kingdoms and even raised a family but he
never wanted to leave he dealt so far
into his fantasy world that I soon
realized he preferred his dream over the
real world now he reminded him that this
was all merely an illusion but he
wouldn't listen to me he stated that if
he was ever forced to leave he would
immediately end his life I tried to keep
him happy for as long as I could and I
responded back to him book keeper how
long was the dream from his point of
view and after a long pause he said 200
years doctor I did my best I firmly held
onto him for 200 years
a sweet as dreams maybe eventually we
all have to wake up
I woke almost immediately after believe
you spent a hundred years in his dream
I'm astounded by his foolishness but
such a shame to have lost a brilliant
mind to his own delusions shortly after
the report was filed surveillance showed
dr. fate is flipping another small paper
into scp-1234 miss ep 12:30 began
showing its usual here was born greeting
once again when asked what the note said
doctor declined to give a detail comment
simply stating that he just gave it some
friendly advice addendum 1230 a during
initial testing SCP 1231 asked dreaming
personnel if it could be relocated to an
area with many books preferably fiction
so that it could think of even better
ways to construct its fantasy escapes
after numerous experiments were
performed to ensure that scp-1234 quest
was accepted an SCP 1230 as been
relocated to site 12s library rest in
peace professor
thank you all for listening if indeed
you still are and you are all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Jim's Saba Maximus Decimus arbiter
Sewell dr. bright darius time Justin day
o philia gray der naam and je vous Jack
Corey Barker rune in and dr. Proctor
thank you all so much for your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos on some other cool
stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
volgen thank you
you